you've seen them I've seen it through
episode 8 which is what I want to talk
about okay that was a really tough
episode episode I have to really
compliment you on your performance
because there's so much there's so much
in it and but it is also like such a
strong turn for the show just because it
you know people have died it's not it's
always kind of been and played in that
space but this is a real moment I think
the the turn that congressman Harris's
character takes the decisions he makes
the decision he makes at the end of that
episode I think is sadly emblematic of
what might have happened to somebody in
that position at that time you know
hopefully we have come past that but I
think you know I think that that might
have been something that that character
would have considered doing if he was
put in that position and facing you know
total career destruction and that in
that moment so and I thought that our
writers did a really beautiful job sort
of you know giving Chuck and I the space
to sort of figure that out and and for
us to kind of step out of the half hour
comedy box for a second and do something
that was very unexpected and very
serious I mean it was hard to do on many
levels as a gay man was taught to do as
Tom Watkins and I are in a relationship
so that's also an extra layer of like
seeing somebody in that position it's
not great yeah so it was but I really
applaud David and Jordan for for for
just leaning into that whole story
because when we talked about it I was
like are we really gonna get into this
we're really gonna do this
and then they didn't and then they yeah
I mean the episode title is just you
know a heartbreaker once you finish
watching it
were you surprised did you see that
coming
or did you um I think with as someone
who's watched a fair amount of
television over the years I think as
soon as as soon as you get to the get to
his door that's when I was like oh this
has been quietly because but I mean I
think what's so interesting is that
scene in a 20/20 context
it feels it's it's one of those sharp
reminders that this show is not set
today no unfortunately now on the flip
side of that in that episode
I'm also very I'm curious to see how
this all the audience sort of response
to that storyline I also I have not seen
208 yet but I assume that the Trump
children are still involved those
horrible children are the truth I I
think that went over my head a little
bit and that's a bad thing to admit but
I think I don't know but maybe you
didn't make it into the cut but I
remember in the script after they
destroy our whole apartment yeah
characters babysitting three kids they
destroy the entire place and then the
nanny comes back and gets them and she
says Don jr. Eric Ivanka you're you're
right I do remember that now cheese I
had okay I go into this lockdown not
lockdown mode but sometimes I'm just
like especially like you know watching
older movies like yeah like I was
watching that because was on HBO max and
I was like I'll watch two weeks notice
that rom-com with Sandra Bullock and he
grin and you know figured it'd be fun
escapism and Donald Trump has an
extended cameo in that film he yeah it's
like Hugh Grant's character is a real
estate developer so I guess it makes
sense for Donald to show up at a fancy
party I totally forgot about that I know
he pops up in weird things all over the
place yeah on that time period you're
like what the hell who is this guy
he just wanted to be on camera I think
it was and maybe I'm incorrect but I
think it was the Simpsons was the first
show to predict that he would become
president and like mm I think I think it
is like yes cuz there to see episode
where Lisa becomes president and she has
to sweep up his mess yeah okay Lord
crazy crazy times